Turns into Durga if you treat her
property,
and I didn't use dirt because I wanted
to show that I actually got accused by
someone being a racist because I did
this.
It was quite funny because they said,
well,
you use the into orders to indicate
chaos in the Greco Roman goddess to
indicate benevolence.
And that was obviously an indication of
life fundamental pathology.
Anyways,
it is.
I just want them to show that the idea
of the benevolent God isn't limited to a
single culture.
You know,
there's Diana,
she's got a lot of breasts.
That's what's,
that's what's down in front there.
So she's like the nourishing element of
being the best way to think about it and
the nourishing element of being emerges
in this sort of fashion.
So that's the differentiation of the
archetype.
So way at the back there's the predatory
serpent chaos that lurks in the
background.
And then that fragments.
I'll did one more differentiated.
So I would in one direction into the
feminine and the Feminine.
This is a tough one because there's this
weird interaction here with,
with gender and archetype,
you know,
so.
So here's something to think about,
and I'm,
I'm,
I'm floundering on this because I have
for a long time because it's very
difficult.
Which gender of person are you most
likely to see on the cover of men's
magazine?
A woman,
my gender and most likely to see on the
cover of Woman's magazine.
Why?
Why is that?
Yes,
that's right.
I think that's why I think that's why.
And that means that they're both
possessed by the same archetype in a
different way.
And the archetype is the architect will
feminine fundamentally and for Women The
archetypal feminine is a judge and a and
an ideal,
the judge is,
well,
how far do you deviate from that?
The ideal is to what degree can you
emulate?
And then from them it's the same damn
thing.
The judge elements exactly the same
thing and the possession element,
while it's slightly different,
but it's not that different,
you know,
so,
but it's a strange thing because the
visual image,
general digital images that the
feminine.
So it's a strange because I don't think
the architectural structures were the
same men and women.
So part of it,
the way I've tried to figure this out,
it's like the sun is the sun,
the like the mail,
not the shining sun,
although it's also that it's like,
but women obviously have an element of
them that can be heroic and adversarial,
just like man.
But then in women that's complicated
because the other primary elements of
their Ba is the maternal feminine
element.
And so.
But that's complicated because women or
men can also be quite maternal.
Like for mammals,
predatory mammals,
mandarin unbelievably nurturing and
feminine.
No grizzly bears.
We just eat our own problems.
Know.
So men are,
they're quite feminine as well as being
masculine.
So I kinda think of it this way.
It's like if you're thinking about what
your archetipal personality structure
is,
it's for men.
The hero is at the forefront and the
mother,
the feminine modern,
restorative behind that.
And for women it's reversed.
The Feminine Mother is sort of forefront
and the heroes behind that.
But both of the archetypes are,
are,
are operative.
So,
so you can think about that.
You can see,
see what you make of it.
But
you know,
because he might say,
well why would women isn't reasonable to
presuppose that for women,
the feminine represents the unknown just
like he does for man.
And I don't think it is just like it is
for men because I think for women
there's an element of the patriarchal
structure that's more unknown Mathius
for men,
you know,
and I think you see the reaction to that
in part,
you see the reaction to that in the
feminist movement because the patriarchy
is like the tyrannical father,
you know,
and the patriarchy exists,
but it's not the tyrannical father is
not the entire substrate of culture.
It's just ridiculous.
But I think because women are,
you know,
in some sense they're outsiders to the
male dominance hierarchy,
that
the male dominance hierarchy is more
contaminated by the unknown for women
than it is for math.
And I think it's more likely to be
interpreted as the tyrannical father
because of that.
So anyways,
I can't exactly sorted out because he
ended up with nest problems,
you know,
so in so far as your primary mode of
being as feminine,
then your secondary motor being as
masculine,
you're gonna have all the
characteristics of something masculine
and all the characteristics of something
feminine,
but the manner in which they manifest
themselves,
that's going to be different and I just
can't sort that out too damn
complicated.
Plus I think that that is what we're
sorting out right now in our culture.
You know,
ever since women got the ability to
control their reproductive function,
which was probably at least in part a
consequence of an aide prior
psychological transformation,
right?
Because you could say,
well the pill for women,
but then you could say,
well what was the precondition for
creating a society in which the person
who invented the pill didn't get killed.
You know,
because the Catholic church,
for example,
was not happy.
We build was invented.
Seriously,
not happy and no wonder know sold.
Obviously there had to be some shifting
in the underlying conceptual landscape
in relationship to the relationship
between men and women.
For that invention to even have come
out,
you know,
I think you can really see that starting
know if you read the classic Russian and
all those,
you can see that push towards equality
to characterize women was really alive
and well in 19th century Russia.
I'm on mirrors to call aristocracy,
so you know like it,
it has a pretty lengthy history that's
associated a wiping of gender
differences across western countries.
Meet the,
the,
the waning.
You mean that widening of personality
differences?
So big five differences are wider and
more here and countries and depression
of incidents.
I don't know.
I don't know how to answer that.
Exactly.
So the point is that if you look at
personality differences between men and
women in the modern world,
the most egalitarian cultures have the
biggest personality differences,
the gender,
and so the technical reason for that is
all the environmental variability has
been eliminated and so all that's left
is genetic variability and there,
and that's not masked in some sense by
the environmental variability.
So it's powerful and profound,
but it definitely shows that there's a
lot of powerful genetic variability.
Definitely it's powerful evidence for
that,
you know,
but it also could be,
it could easily be that didn't
necessarily fit what you're aiming for
in it.
The galitary in society is the right for
everyone to be different in their own
way,
whatever that happens to be,
you know,
and obviously that's going to be a
limited,
right to some degree.
So any galitary and society wouldn't
necessarily eradicate personality
differences.
That would be a bloody totalitarian
societies.
Like get rid of all the differences.
Well,
to the degree that you're a female and
whatever the hell that means
fundamentally,
and I mail,
if we have to be the same,
then that's going to be a function of
increased tense.
What would you call control on the part
of the state?
You know,
to the degree that that's intrinsic,
we don't know what,
how much of it's intrinsic.
I would be very hesitant to say not.
I mean let's,
let's be real about this
additionally complicated because
architects like they're universally,
but you understand both the female and
the male president.
I know you understand and as personality
traits,
the masculine stereotypical traits and
feminine stereotypical traits across
genders,
but people,
any person have you done there can be
this as much or whatever,
like they're not opposites,
so wondering if it's complicated because
any individual person that is manifested
in parts of both at once in some.
No,
it's definitely.
It's definitely complicated,
but it's also a prerequisite for
longterm relationships between men and
women.
Right.
If we weren't a lot the same or at least
capable of being the same,
then we will be able to understand each
other at all.
I mean,
he didn't.
I don't know if we,
if we do what we do,
we do more than other creatures that
have our complexity,
that's for sure.
So yeah,
and you know,
it's certainly the case that if you look
at a given individual and you look at
the variability of their personality,
Leighton's behavior,
the variability within a person is
generally greater than the average
variability within the population.
So you know,
human beings,
if you're an extrovert,
you can be extremely introverted.
Like there's not very many extroverts at
a funeral.
Now the noisiest people at a funeral
will be the extroverts,
but there are going to be hard to be
noisy at all,
you know,
and an introvert can find themselves in
the situation where they can't shut up.
You know?
So there's a lot of inter individual
variability.
I actually think that one of the indexes
of psychological health is the
maximizations of individual variability
because you should be able to be
extremely compassionate,
for example,
when you're dealing with a sick baby and
extremely uncompassionate when you're
dealing with someone who's,
you know,
using their illness as an excuse not to
pull their own weight,
but you need both of those.
Right?
And you know,
you'll end up with an average point as a
consequence of your genetic structure
and maybe your,
your socialization and sort of up to you
to widen yourself all across the full
spectrum so that you can call and those
abilities when it's necessary.
I think that's part of what
differentiation as a person actually
means.
You know,
because you,
you come to be able to do more things
and so you can match yourself much more
carefully to the immediate demands of
the situation.
So yeah,
we have the questions.
Okay.
So the,
the assemble for,
for uh,
normally the feminine differentiates
into the negative feminine,
the positive feminine part of the issue
is how do you get more of the positive
and keep the negative that day.
And you know,
that's,
that's a question that people have to
ask themselves at the personal,
the individual at that level of the
individual interaction with other people
and with themselves.
But then it also works as a
representation of the unknown and nature
as such.
It's because in some ways those are the
same thing.
So that's,
you know,
that's a differentiation.
So,
so this is the relationship between the
hero archetype in the feminist.
So what you have here is the chaos
dragon differentiating itself into the
feminine,
which is half positive,
half negative,
and the feminine.
They're being manifested in the form of
the Virgin Mary with Christ on her lap.
You saw at the same representation when
we were looking at Isis and horace,
and what's really quite cool about that
as you see,
she's surrounded by this,
this matador law,
this,
uh,
you know,
almond shaped
opening fundamentally.
And you see this as something that
renaissance artists get a lot.
You see along the edges of the Mandurah,
there's all these little baby hits that
are popping up with wings on them and
those are called Pootie,
you know,
and it's very common that when you see
representations of married with,
with,
with the cosmos sort of billowing out
behind her because that's what you see.
It's like a whole into time and space
that there's all these potential beings
that are surrounding,
you know,
it's these little baby heads with
weight.
It's like,
what the hell are they?
Well,
what this thing,
you know,
it's so strange.
I went to a museum in New York where a
number of renaissance paintings of this
type were,
were arrayed in this one room.
It's like a rude word,
affiliate donors,
Nazy Room.
And there are people from all over the
world and they're looking at these damn
paintings.
And they say,
you know this,
it's like it's married and she's sitting
on the moon and there's a bunch of like
winged baby heads around like,
what the hell's that all about?
Everybody's looking at it like,
wow,
you know,
there's really something to this.
And it's like you've kept them on the
shoulder and you say,
well,
why did you travel from like Cincinnati
to come to this museum to look like this
woman who he don't even believe in
sitting on the Chris Moon surrounded by
baby hands?
They don't know.
I have no idea why they're there.
They're fascinated by the painting.
Right?
Fascinating.
If life interrupts a reasons,
but you know,
you don't even notice how absurd it is
until you take the picture of a bit.
What the hell are these things,
these Pootie,
you know,
I think what they are essential beings.
That's the representation.
So Mary represents the feminine domain
from which potential being emergence,
which is perfectly reasonable way of
characterizing defendant in
architecture.
You know what are the pictures I will
show you,
which I just love is married to another
representation of Mary and she's got
Christ in her hands and she's holding
them up to the left and her foot.
Your foot is gone.
A snake's head,
which I think is so cool because if you
look at that picture and you strip away
the Judeo Christian presuppositions and
you just look at it like a damn
biologist,
you think,
well,
of course that's what she's doing.
You know?
It's like Mama chimp keeps the damn
infant away from the snakes and that's
the archetype and of course it's the
archetype because that is what you do.
That's what you do when you're a mother,
especially if you have nice edible
babies that snakes like to eat and that
is certainly something that
characterizes us in our evolutionary
past.
So it's no wonder it's a divine
archetype,
you know?
Of course it is.
How could it not be the.
You might say,
well,
I don't believe in that.
It's like the hell.
Does that mean you don't believe in
that?
No,
I.
I can't even understand what that means
anymore.
When I think about such things,
it's like there's,
you don't have an option about bleeding
and that it's just the fundamental
nature of reality,
you know?
Is that the mother of God and it's what
you mean?
It all depends on how much divinity is
embodied in your child and believe me,
once you have that child,
you're going to think,
hey,
there's a pretty big chunk of divinity
and did that child.
No one knows.
Makes to get that.
I'm going to keep it away from predators
and you know,
evil doers and try to raise it into the
best possible things.
Like you may say,
you don't believe that.
It was like,
what the hell do you know in so far as
you're a good mother,
you'll be acting that I was going mad
and I'm not going to say that's wrong
because I actually think it's right.
I think the child is a container of the
divine and that your job as a mother is
to allow that child can facilitate the
development of that child into the
mythological.
That's what you're up to and that's a
holy mission in so far as you could use
that word to describe anything and I
failed to see how that is not real.
I think it's the most real thing.
So when I also think the degree to which
you're going to be able to do that as a
monitoring will be the most rewarding
thing you'll ever do in your life.
And you'll figure that out.
It's a powerful thing and your whole
life can change this completely.
Once you have your own child,
it's like they're not like other
children.
They're your old shot.
It's like they're the most important
thing in the world right then and from
then on,
if you're healthy,
it's like your priorities shift.
It's not about you anymore.
And that's a sacrifice,
you know,
it's a real sacrifice.
The sacrifice that women are called on
for me and itself,
two major sacrifice.
Okay?
So the,
you know,
the mother gives birth to the hero.
Okay?
That's Hercules.
It's not priced as Hercules and this
particular representation,
and she's,
I love this representation is.
It's so cool.
So Hercules',
he's out there in the darkness on the
water,
so it's the water retail,
so that's where he's situated themselves
voluntarily and he's,
is he in this container now?
It's a good thing you can take about
that as a maternal container or even
think about it as cultural protection
doesn't really matter.
And then he's got this clock and if you
look on the cloud,
but it's got these weird bumps on it.
But if you look at the bottom,
what do you understand this?
Those aren't farms.
Those are our eyes.
So He's just like,
Marta,
he's got this club and what's the club?
It's like attention.
That's it.
You know what,
if you're going to clump something you
had to us to pay attention to it.
Maybe it's like a rampaging light.
And then if you turn away from it,
well it's gonna eat you.
So the clubs useless without the
attention.
But you know the picture says club,
which is a weapon.
A weapon is A.
Metta is a form of mental attention,
or sorry,
I've bought my reverse.
Attention is a better weapon.
It's the ultimate weapon against the
unknown.
And so there's,
her has got his eyes wide open,
he's peering out into the darkness he's
got this lion had because he killed a
lion and you know,
men used to do that,
you know,
and they were shepherds out in the
desert in the Middle East.
One of the things they had to do was
kill a lion with a spear.
It's like,
that's really worth thinking about,
man,
that's hard to do that.
That would be very hard to be very
friendly to do that.
And so,
but men used to do that.
So that's really something to think
about.
Anyways,
so he's got this light into going into
and he's King of the beasts,
roughly speaking.
So it represents the thing that's at the
top of the dominance hierarchy.
You want to know that because otherwise
he couldn't have understood the lion
king and the lion is a solar beast
because it's yellow golden word sounded.
You know,
what's a daylight creature?
It's out there on the belt where
everything's son.
So it's associated with the Sonnet
illumination and enlightenment.
And so it's like lions,
son Sutton with ice goes to conquer the
unknown.
That's what the mother does,
if she raises the proper son,
so I know she's also doing that for the
door,
but again,
that's complicated because women are
complicated and their role is very,
very complex and so to some degree
they're the hero,
but to some degree they're the mother of
the hero and those are,
I would say,
I don't know.
I don't know how to,
how to configure that.
It's you could say,
okay,
you,
you could say that in some sense of a
conscious mind or gives up her own
individual heroism as a sacrifice to the
potential hero is a Mumford children's
and that's worth thinking about because
my guess is that for most of you,
your mother did that,
you know,
now you want to,
my wife had a three months about what do
you want her great grandmother's shoes.
Her grandmother shoots.
She really liked her grandmother,
a very feminine person,
you know,
like cookie making,
Apple Pie,
they shadow play grandmother,
you know,
she had people in the old folks home
even when she was 80 and she was really
cheerful and tough,
but she's a great person.
I really liked her,
but when my wife dream diversity driven,
she was trying on her shoes and the
shoes were too small,
you know,
and that was very interesting because it
seemed to indicate to me,
and she loved your grandmother now
there's no doubt about that,
that role,
despite her grandmother having fulfilled
us so well it wasn't announced and you
know,
women have kind of decided that and
maybe that's for the best because now
there's all these smart women's running
around doing useful things and you know,
that's probably good,
but exactly how to sort that out.
You figure it out.
So what time is it.